I think a lot of founders have heard
horror stories about co-founder breakups
and their takeaway is like, oh, I'm a
genius. I'm just not going to have a
co-founder. Oh, I fixed the problem.
>> [laughter]
>> I pre-fixed the problem.
It's the best sort of thing.
This is Dalton plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about co-founder
fights
and co-founder breakups. We have a lot
of experience in both of these.
>> [laughter]
>> Should we start with breakups first or
fights first? Where where where do you
want to What's logical? Let's start at
the beginning. Um
co-founders, okay. What do we even mean
by co-founders? Yeah, so traditionally
when you start a tech startup, yes, you
don't do it by yourself and if you look
to history of how a lot of the biggest
companies started,
um
they tended to have co-founders. I guess
there's examples of families I'm
thinking of non-tech companies where you
started with your family. But usually
there was, you know, another person like
the canonical Steve Jobs
>> [laughter]
>> Steve Wozniak, it was it was two people.
Maybe to start by addressing that. I
think a lot of founders have heard
horror stories about co-founder breakups
which we're about to talk about in a
second.
>> Yes.
>> And their takeaway is like, oh, I'm a
genius.
I'm just not going to have a co-founder.
Oh, I fixed the problem. [laughter]
I pre-fixed the problem.
It's the best sort of thing. And it's
like, man, you guys sure spend a lot of
time talking about co-founder problems.
>> Have you even thought of my genius?
>> a genius. Um
>> [laughter]
>> Well, again, let's address that. Let's
let's steel man that argument. It is
true that
if you remove a co-founder, [laughter]
the odds that you will get in a
co-founder dispute dip to zero.
>> Yes.
>> Clever.
>> [laughter]
>> However, there are many things in life
where I think they're a good idea, but
they involve taking a risk and they
don't have a 100% success rate.
>> Getting married?
>> Sure.
>> Having kids?
>> Kids who like you?
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Taking any kind of risk? I don't know,
putting yourself out there, starting a
company.
>> Sure.
>> Starting a company, yeah. Starting
[laughter] a company is very risky. It
does not 100% chance of success.
>> Therefore.
>> Therefore, don't do anything. [laughter]
Don't do anything if you want to avoid
problems. So again, to be very specific,
the number one cause of death when
you're a founder
is
it just sort of dies on the vine and you
run out of hope and you give up on it.
>> Losing the faith.
>> And the issue of not having a co-founder
is you don't have anyone to talk about
and you don't feel like you're on a
mission, you don't feel like you're on
an adventure.
>> Yes.
>> Not having a co-founder is fine for a
lot of people. So again, I don't want to
get turn this into a debate where we say
>> But pooling the faith
>> is is very helpful and the numbers
don't apply about this. The outcomes are
there.
>> So I love this setup because what we're
the reason why we're making this video
is not
to convince you that the answer to the
SAT question is don't have a co-founder.
>> Don't take the SAT.
>> [laughter]
>> We're like, the SAT is hard, don't take
the SAT, Michael. That's the
>> The reason why we're making this video
is that doing this thing that we think
you should do, we're going to give you
some hints when you hit some rocks. And
maybe let's
put a final point on the why you should
have a co-founder bit.
>> Yes.
>> Let's put it this way. We know a lot of
the single founders that have been
successful as well
>> Yes.
>> and sometimes we funded them at YC.
>> All of those people created
co-founder-like
>> relationships
>> environments and relationships that did
fill the void. So whether it was
employees, whether it was advisors,
whether it was friends, there is no way
you can get around not having someone to
talk to all the time to bounce ideas off
of.
>> No, right?
>> Anything to add there?
>> And I feel like those stories are just
like
because they don't make the headline
story, they're not told.
>> Yeah.
>> But I completely agree with you. So,
what happens when you are fighting with
your co-founder? In my experience,
there are two realities.
You are friends with this person
or you're not friends with this person.
What I have found is when you are
friends with your co-founder, there will
be something in the startup that happens
that will frustrate the hell out of you,
and you will have a particularly harsh
thing that you want to say, but because
you're friends with this person,
more often than not, you're not going to
say it, or you're going to put it
slightly differently, or you're going to
ask yourself,
"If I were on the receiving end of this,
would this motivate me or not?"
Unfortunately, when you're not friends
with this person, sometimes it's easier
just to
boom, boom, fire, fire, and then that
can create problems.
>> Yeah.
>> That can create real problems. So,
that's probably the first thing that I
see with a co-founder fight is when it's
initiated stupidly, right? Like, you're
going to have to fight about some stuff,
but it's just like, can we avoid the
dumb ones,
>> [snorts]
>> you know? Like, "Oh, these guys raised
money, why couldn't you go raise money?"
So, I think that's a big one. Where else
are you seeing co-founder fights?
>> The biggest root cause is that
you end up getting into the relationship
for the wrong reasons. And so, for
better or worse, I can't help but
think that all human relationships are
fundamentally similar in some ways.
>> Sure.
>> Not always.
>> For sure.
>> But, you know, if if you end up getting
thrown into a pretty intense experience
with a complete stranger, and you've
taken no time to understand the other
person, the chances that you'll have a
disagreement are pretty high. You just
don't even have the same context.
>> Yes.
>> Um and so, the biggest issue I see is
that
they don't even It's like strangers
trying to navigate the beginning part of
a relationship, and then it sort of
dawns on them, "Oh man, this person's a
stranger, and I got into this
relationship for the wrong reasons."
>> Yes.
>> Um and I'm mad at myself.
Let me do some lashing out.
>> And so, what that looks like in practice
is you can't even agree on really basic
stuff such as the name of the company.
>> Sure.
>> Such as what idea are we working on?
Such as what should I be doing with my
time and what should you be doing with
your time?
>> It's interesting cuz like there's almost
no basis for there being trust.
>> Yeah.
>> And if there's no trust, we can fight
about anything.
>> [laughter]
>> Just just throw something out there.
>> Forever.
>> [laughter]
>> You can have endless arguments
about everything.
>> [laughter]
>> And especially cuz you're the boss or
like everything's on the table.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> So no, I totally agree with that one. I
think another thing that was a
misconception that I had
was that each co-founder is going to add
an equal amount of value at all times.
And I see a lot of
resentment build up when somebody feels
like oh, I'm grinding and my
co-founder's not. As if like we're all
working on the car factory line
and anyone who's not working that the
cars aren't moving through. It hasn't
been my experience things are always
exactly that way. Well, what's been your
experience?
>> Yeah, I mean
there has to be a mutual respect.
>> Yes.
>> And what happens is there's all these
superficial things in an office hours
that someone will want to talk about and
then you just keep digging and digging
and digging and digging and at the
bottom is I don't respect
the job or the thing that this person is
doing.
>> Mhm.
>> And that it doesn't really matter what
all the upper layers are. It's pretty
hard to fix that if at the core is a is
a lack of a mutual respect.
>> One of the things amongst friends that
can create that respect is
I feel like I'm working hard and I don't
feel like you are. And
it was funny in in my first company, we
had four co-founders. And looking back,
what I tell founders a lot is
at any given time, I think we had two
and a half co-founders.
And, you know, that means like one and a
half people were probably not
engaged in the core thing moving the
company forward.
>> At that time.
>> And only over years did I kind of see
how that all balanced out. And it wasn't
always the same one and a half people.
>> And this makes me [laughter] think of
like a another point we touched on a
minute ago, but look, man,
just like relationships,
>> yeah.
>> everyone else's is different. And if you
try to stand in judgement
of how other people made it work,
>> yeah.
>> you're wasting your time.
>> Yes.
>> And so some people will be like,
"Michael, you were four founders and,
you know, you had Emmett and, you know,
blah blah blah, you know, that has
nothing to do with my
>> start-up."
>> It's like
What what what I'm going [laughter] with
this is you're right, that is different.
>> Yes.
>> But it worked for them and you built
Twitch. You built an enduring thing that
still lives on and is bigger than all of
you guys.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And so if you want to build a big
company that's bigger
>> than
>> than all of you individually, don't
assume you could just blindly copy or
cargo cult another person's playbook and
it will necessarily work for you.
>> Nope.
>> And so to me, the biggest learning from
your co-founding experience
is
you guys made it work versus you must
have four co-founders and they must be
this and you must act this way.
>> No. No.
>> Right?
>> No.
>> So, let's move into
it's not going to work. I think there's
an interesting transition between
co-founders fighting, which I think, you
know, is going to happen,
and co-founders fighting that when we're
talking to them, we know
>> Yeah.
>> they're going to break up
before they break up. We know the trust
is destroyed. I think that's a really
important time in a startup because I I
always fear with startups like
when you really know the probability of
success is zero,
most important thing is to stop wasting
time.
And you know, sometimes I see people
living in this like we haven't decided
we're going to break up yet, but
obviously
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> But like everything is dysfunctional,
it's not going to get repaired. And it's
like, can we get through that phase as
quickly as possible? [laughter]
Like
>> Yeah, I mean, what this looked like to
me in office hours with a with a YC
company
is
they would want to meet with me without
the other person.
>> Oh my god.
>> basically want to present some facts
about why that person
>> about why Yeah. And so
>> kind of what I learned to do after many
years of this is
to say the facts don't matter. I'm not
the judge and jury. You don't need to
present the case to me. If you don't
think it's going to work and it's bad
enough such that you're trying to meet
with me and present facts to me, that
sounds pretty bad. I think this is
pretty far gone. And so
counterintuitively, I think, I'd be
like, let's not talk about the facts. It
doesn't actually matter. Let's just try
to create a go-forward plan that is the
most positive for
all parties involved to not work
together anymore.
>> Yes.
>> So that everyone feels good about how
they were treated, they feel good about
the process.
>> Yes.
>> There wasn't a lot of like legal threats
or problems. You just go your separate
ways and
there's not like um
permanent toxic waste in the
relationship. You're just like, cool,
we're just going to go our separate ways
and everyone is going to be okay with
it.
>> Yes.
>> Um that's what I learned to do. And it
works a lot if people are super
professional and adult about it.
>> I think the thing that always frustrated
me when giving
>> [snorts]
>> office hours on this topic was
how unhelpful third parties can be.
>> Yep.
>> Um you know, co-founder breakups
extremely common with pre-product market
fit early stage companies, right?
Another way of saying a pre-product
market market early stage is like it has
created no value. So, like the stock
that you have is worthless.
>> Correct. You have nothing.
>> And so,
in a situation
where you're having a co-founder breakup
and the stock is worth nothing, paying
lawyers a bunch of money
makes no sense.
>> It's idiotic.
>> Well, you're fighting over nothing.
You're fighting over ego.
>> You're spending
>> money
>> [laughter]
>> over nothing.
I don't mind if you fight. Can you just
also not spend money with your lawyers
to fight?
>> And, you know, the lawyer is trained
well, there's a 0.00000001%
chance this becomes Google.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you need to fight like And it's
like,
sorry, when when there's infinite zeros
like after the decimal point, it means
there's no chance it becomes Google. It
means you're fighting over something
that's nothing not worth anything.
And the problem is is that a lawyer can
suck up infinite amount of your
>> Yep.
>> anger
and monetize it.
It makes me feel dirty just saying that
out loud.
>> That's what that's That's the the
service provider. Oh, the client wanted
services, which is to write mean letters
to the former co-founder.
>> [laughter]
>> That's a service.
>> And I I will provide it.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, the number of times I then see
founders in a situation where it's like,
"Oh, crap. Like,
not only are we in a deeper fight, but
we now have like debt." I've seen
situations where an individual founder
is leaving has debt
>> Yeah.
>> on a on a company that's not worth
anything.
>> Yeah.
>> And like, man, I hope your feelings feel
better cuz like your bank account
is going to suffer. So, a lot of what
we've tried to do at YC is kind of
create like a basic framework
to deal with these breakups.
And like, what I love about giving these
off hours is you know, at YC, we have
these written down.
>> Yep.
>> So, like I you know that I didn't I'm
not taking a side. I didn't invent this.
Like, you can
post fact check me. Jesus. You can post
fact check me and like you know I'm
going to tell the exact same thing to
the other co-founder cuz it's also
written down.
>> Yeah.
>> And maybe we should talk about some of
these standards, some of these like,
"Hey, how a co-founder breakup should
go."
>> So, again, just start with
the way it should go is sort of no fault
from both sides.
>> Yes.
>> And so, again, unless you catch them
committing a felony, okay, that's that's
a outside the scope of this
conversation. But, for the most part,
make it no fault.
>> Yes.
>> Don't
try to ruin the other person. Don't try
to ruin the reputation. Don't try to
contact the investors and all this other
crap. So, make it no fault.
>> Yes.
>> Optimize for cleanliness for both sides.
So, that requires the least amount of
mental angst and anger to separate ways.
Make it so that you don't say things you
can't take back.
>> Yes.
>> Preserve the ability to interact with
them in the future and the employees.
You know, keep your mouth shut
basically. Both parties should.
>> Yes.
>> And then, vesting is good. Hopefully,
you have vesting.
Vesting protects both parties in this
case because it makes it cleaner to
separate.
>> Yes.
>> I think that oftentimes what we tell
founders is that if you're pre-product
market fit
and the company's going to continue
operating and you're the leaving party,
you have to understand that the vast
majority of the value this company could
create hasn't been created yet.
>> Yep.
>> And so, regardless of your vesting,
um you need to make sure that that
company has as much equity as possible
to motivate the people who are there,
the people that might be hired to come
create value. I often talk to that
person first and I basically I'm saying,
"You get to go and live your life and
that company, if it ever creates value,
you're going to get some money for it,
even though you don't have to contribute
to it
anytime. Like, you get to hedge.
The founder staying doesn't. Make sure
the founder staying has as much
incentive as humanly possible to try to
make that thing valuable.
>> [laughter]
>> Because
>> Well, and again, it reminds me of the
the lawyer thing, which is legal advice
or certain types of advisers will be
like trying to help you craft the ways
to maximally screw the other party and
extract every penny of value. And
basically, just like scorched earth the
situation.
>> Yes.
>> And guess what? They will take your
money to go do that.
>> Yes.
>> And then their reputation does not
suffer because they are lawyers.
>> Nope.
>> Whereas you are still you have a career
and everyone will remember you from
doing the scorched earth thing. And so,
I would encourage people to think about
this as like a game theory infinite
games situation, which is if you handle
this
unremarkably in a good way, like if you
do
if you're unremarkably, it's like, "Oh,
yeah, I worked we we worked together, it
didn't work out. I went and did my own
thing and it was no big deal."
Very good for your career.
>> Yes.
>> But being known as the super litigious
scorched earth person, you're never
going to work again.
>> Nope.
>> And your lawyer's not going to tell you
that.
>> Nope.
>> And so, if you're just thinking about
this, this is actually going on your
permanent record
>> Yes.
>> that you were like cool about it and
didn't cause a lot of problems and is
likely like the most important
takeaway from this part, right, man?
>> I completely agree. And I think that for
the founder who's staying, I I always
try to reframe it in their head because
I think oftentimes
anyone who feels bad, like the first
instinct is to make yourself the victim.
>> Yep.
>> And I'm kind of like, "Well,
that person's leaving and you're
staying. So, it's like
they probably like you know, like let's
not debate victims, but like I you
probably don't deserve
>> the bigger victim. Let's have a debate,
Michael. Michael, please tell us please
take my side
>> [laughter]
>> about what a victim I am.
>> Yes, like what what I'm experiencing,
right?
>> And what I often tell that person is you
have an opportunity to be generous.
Um especially like if you've got funding
when it comes to severance, like you
have an opportunity to make sure that
that co-founder who's leaving can get
back on their feet, live their life, go
move on to the next thing.
And your incentive to do it is one, if
this is your friend, like you want your
friend to be okay, right? And then two,
understand that everyone in your company
is looking at you right now.
And like this is the person who at least
theoretically you trusted the most. How
you treat them
>> [clears throat]
>> will you treat anyone else better? And
it is so cheap to be nice.
>> [laughter]
>> And and it creates so many positive
dividends amongst the other people who
are staying, but it's very very hard to
be nice when you think of yourself as
the victim.
Right? When you're the victim
then it's like, well, it's that person
has what's coming to them.
And I would say that if you think of
yourself as the responsible party
and you act that way, often you don't
trigger victimness on the other side,
too.
Whereas like so often I'll see the
lawyers be like, "Well, you better
protect yourself because like they might
come after you." And you inadvertently
the founder who's staying triggers the
fight.
>> Yes.
>> And you're just like, "What are you
doing?"
>> [laughter]
>> We generally tell people, "Hey, even if
you vested, like get down to under 5% of
the company, if it's within the first
year, under 2%. Do reasonable severance,
sign clean paperwork
and and peace out, right? Like you could
do that whole thing in a week and spend
like $2,000. If you're not doing that
it's like you're taking a very hard
route. Um
and I would say that like
it's really really important
in these fights, just make sure no one's
taking advantage of you. Any time you're
spending money,
be worried that someone's taking
advantage. [laughter]
>> If there's a Yeah, if there's a service
provider
>> If there's a bill.
>> that is excited to offer you services
and there's a bill and they're paid for
their time and not
>> Mhm. [laughter]
>> Yeah, that's what it is. Yeah.
>> Here's my last piece of advice. It comes
back to what you were saying before.
Who If you're using someone to mediate
this,
don't make them the judge. Don't make
them
>> Because it doesn't matter. If you're not
going to work together anymore, it
doesn't actually matter what happened.
It's irrelevant.
Right?
>> No. And like, come on, it was a startup.
The expected outcome.
Like this is the expected outcome.
[laughter]
Like don't don't treat this like it's
Google breaking up.
>> Yep.
>> When it's not Google breaking up. And I
think often times service providers in
their minds, they're like company
public company.
>> And I would kind of bring this back to
one of the original points I made it on
this one, which is if you handle this
well, this is a non-mortal wound.
Like part of the reason there's so much
I never want to have a co-founder
because I heard my friend and this
happened to them and blah blah blah
blah. It's cuz it was handled horribly.
And if you handle this well, this is a
footnote in both of your careers.
>> Yes.
>> This is a footnote in the history of the
company, right? Apple had a third
co-founder. Remember that guy? And then
they bought him out and then like it was
fine. Like the company lived on. And so
the better you can handle this,
the less likely this is going to be a
big deal
>> Yes.
>> in your life.
>> The more likely that you and your former
co-founder will still be friends. Yeah.
So, the quick takeaways.
Don't get fooled by service providers.
Don't spend a lot of money.
Clean paperwork, no fault.
If you are pre-product market fit, even
if any of the founders leaving, even if
you vested a lot of stock, you should
probably willing to give a lot back.
Um
and
if you're leaving in under a year, even
more so, right? After a number of years,
5% typical. Under a year,
1%, 2%, sometimes less than 1%.
And when you're the leaving co-founder,
understand that you want to motivate
the team that remains to make that stock
worth something. Yes, and you get to go
and you get to do something else.
If you're the co-founder that remains,
understand how you treat this person
is how the people around you think
they're going to get treated. And don't
make your poor startup advisor into
judge and jury. On this point, I maybe
I'll be a little bit
less nice than Dalton. Like, we don't
care.
>> [laughter]
>> If you made a list of all the things we
screwed up in our company, it would be
way longer than the things you're pissed
at your co-founder about. [laughter]
This is your life.
And of course, if your co-founder is
breaking the law, doing something
unethical, killing people,
none of this applies.
>> [laughter]
>> I would call the lawyers.
But
just just be smart and nice about it and
it'll work out. Great chat.
>> All right, thanks.